hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video von ihr seht schon julis mit dabei
und ihr seht es auch bereits den titel
eingeblendet wir machen heute einen
nicht a sagen challenge dabei geht es
ganz einfach darum dass jun und ich uns
eine gutes papi compilation bzw das ist
einfach eine waschmaschine und haben uns
ein gutes papi compilation draußen sucht
also süße hundewelpen oder allgemein
hunde die irgendwas machen und wir beide
sind riesige hundefans und jedes mal
wenn wir irgendwie unseren mund
verziehen oder wenn wir gegen die
zusagen oder irgendwie so dann müssen
wir eine an diesen ekelhaften jelly
beans essen das heißt ich würde sagen
wir fangen direkt anbieten
ich habe direkt geladen ich hab gar
nicht an diese chips gedacht das ist
doch süß ja jeder der dann nicht lacht
er doch kein herz also gut leute greift
jetzt einfach mal blind rein und ich
habe diese celli
das ist entweder das schimmelkäse oder
karamell popcorn menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend mailbox
weiter gehts hier freunde der hund liegt
jetzt echt süß in den gruppen aber
kicken wir müssen wieder unsere
gesichter auf null
[Musik]
wir haben beide verkäufers ist das wenn
mein gott juden zuerst ich hier nach
ich habe geld das ich habe entweder ein
verstümmeltes oder gezuckertes popcorn
man schmeckt
jetzt legt eine hand ist der mini
empfinde ich nicht ich musste lachen
weil die ordnen so hoch und runter
gemacht haben
ich will mir so ich bei mir ist es halt
immer so wenn ich sowas sehe dann bin
ich jetzt nicht so dass ich sage
hahahaha war das lustig aber ich ziehe
schauen so die mundwinkel immer hoch
immer noch kurz geruch und ja ist ja
nichts neues
ich ziehe wieder blind irgendwas raus
das hätte ich wirklich nur glück es ist
dachte scheiße entweder erbrochen ist
oder vier sich geil alter wenn ihr
allerdings was sehen wollt freunde wo
ich richtig pech hatte mit essen morgen
um 16 uhr 15 kommt hier auf einem kanal
eine glücksrad challenge ich zeige euch
mal schon mal kleinen vorab ausschnitte
weiß ich es geht also morgen um 16 uhr
15 kommt das wieder auf meinem kanal
aber die beschäftigen sich heute mit
hunden das heißt schauen muss jetzt mal
weiter an
und erinnert mich ein bisschen an den
bund von anker weil er auch so verspielt
ist
nein ich wollte manfred schinner
wolfskin ich habe voll davon träumt so
ein schrank zu haben in meinem
kinderzimmer das also frettchen drin
sind so ein zwei oder so übel wirklich
fragt sarah ich wollte unbedingt
frettchen haben und jetzt auch noch so
ein frettchen hiermit zum golden
retriever wasser kenne ich ja nicht mehr
zurück und guckt euch das an wie süß und
ich wollte gerade zu sagen ihn frettchen
als maul also ja ich muss mal wieder
hier ziehen freunde das heißt dass hier
wird meine nächste frohe
nase popeln oder eine saftige birne was
ist der unterschied zwischen der
saftigen bier nur unter normalen bildet
[Musik]
alter so schmeckt auch kein popel also
ich hab noch nie das nicht nur dass ich
schon meine puppe ling das ist auch
jetzt nicht wo ich sagen würde oder
irgendwie so sondern das halt einfach
einfach dumm ist offensichtlich ja und
dann kurz danach notwendig damit die
szene ist schon süß ich feiere auch beim
a team ja gar nicht nur mit braunen
punkten
mit braunen punkten ich fand es nicht so
süß aber ich war so lustig wieder das
gesagt hat also ich muss mal wieder
eingreifen freunde das nächste was ich
weiß ist
geht aber
jedoch nicht live stift späne oder
banane alter hast du schon mal bleibt
später gegessen noch mal selber
nachdenken über dann doch noch fragen
[Musik]
ja wenn man mit leuten mit solchen
hunden
ja weil die das nicht kennen wenn so
eine maschine irgendwie neben den ist
oder so wieder schön mit augen zur
eingreifen nicht so wie julia einfach
eins raus und was man gern hätte ich
nehme
ich habe keine ahnung was ich weiß nicht
ob es gut oder schlecht ist
guck mal das ist unfassbar dass du
einfach keine emotionen haben es war ein
ziemlicher käse oder verrottetes am
morgen
dreht sich gerade viermal um einfach an
der stelle würde ich das heute wieder
zeitig verbänden meine damen und herren
wenn es euch gefallen hat das gerne mal
einen like da sollen nun endlich das
ganze eventuell noch mal mit einer
anderen judt compilation machen oder so
dann schreibt uns gerne und in die
kommentare
falls einige von euch eventuell
mitbekommen haben oder ich denke es
haben viele von euch mitbekommen haben
wir hatten ein kleines problem ist mit
der luca pizza da haben wir schon viele
viele nachrichtenportale darüber
berichtet wollte nur eben noch kurz
sagen dass wir uns schon den ganzen tag
mit ganz vielen verschiedenen parteien
schon damit beschäftigen und uns damit
auseinandersetzen mit dem kleinen
problemchen und ich werde dazu heute
abend noch eine stellungnahme auf
twitter instagram snapshot dezember
öffentlich habe und natürlich die retter
fällen
[Musik]
ein